uh it is 8 25 here in the east and jill
biden's own department of justice is now
reportedly arguing against
those 450 000
payments to migrants separated at the
border just two months after the
president pushed for it
if in fact because of the the outrageous
behavior of the last administration
you coming across the border whether it
was legal or illegal and you lost your
child
you lost your child it's gone
you deserve some kind of compensation
okay but that's not stopping vulnerable
migrants from being extorted for up to
five thousand dollars by those who
assume they got huge federal payouts one
migrant telling the associated press
apparently i am a millionaire now i
don't have the money to pay for
something like that and i don't know
what i'm supposed to do i'm desperate
fox news contributor and retiring
retired rather acting ice director tom
homan joins us right now tom so you know
after that story came out where
every migrant child separated from their
parents each person in that family would
get 450 000
you know a child and an adult that's
close to a million bucks it sounded like
that was going to happen and now joe
biden's walking away from it what's
going on
well first of all his statement that the
outrageous behavior the trump
administration including myself i'm
still part of that lawsuit what we
enforce the law he ought to try it
because if he tried to enforce the law
we wouldn't have a border like we have
today that was that's just out of
control but look no one should be
getting rewarded for for committing
criminal acts you enter this country
illegally it is a crime and what zero
tolerance is about was about saving
lives remember back then steve children
were dying the democrat lawmakers blamed
the border truck the children are dying
31 of women get sexually assaulted
making that attorney children were dying
coming across that border drugs are
coming across the border killing
thousands of our young people zero
tolerance is about trying something to
save lives having some sort of
consequence some duty some sort of
deterrence that's what law enforcement
is law enforcement uses zero tolerance
on holidays with duis they use zero
tolerance in some cities and
prostitution zero tolerance on the
border under president trump is about
saving lives and nothing more and you
shouldn't reward people that knowingly
violate our laws
well uh fox news tried to get a comment
from the department of justice they have
not picked up the phone yet meanwhile
tom can you explain to us
how uh apparently the fbi is now looking
into these crime tourists who are coming
into the united states and they're
targeting
uh different people in this country
they've carried out scores of burglaries
i think they've netted over two million
dollars who are these crime tourists
well look this has been going on for
decades in my day back when i was a
special agent it was chinese nationals
it was uh nationals from nigeria doing a
lot of extortion a lot of you know doing
the crying tourism thing but there's an
increase in it now because they know
this administration is not strong on law
enforcement most of our major cities are
not strong enforcing the law right now
though it's kind of shifted from china
and nigeria to central america and why
because ms-13 has taken foothold in the
40 states 40 out of 50 states have ms-13
there and there are they are the
founders of extortion they extort the
very same community in which they live
the immigrant community it's it's why
steve i for i have fought against
sanctuary cities that protect these they
say they're protecting the immigrant
community no when you release a public
safety threat back into the public
they're going to reoffend and very
community in which they live the
immigrant community that's why you're
seeing a rising the sanctuary cities in
the in the last law enforcement going on
in the in democrat control cities across
this country you're going to see this
continue to rise
well
unfortunately as we have seen in places
like new york
people who are caught
breaking the law you know these soft on
crime da's they just drop the charges
anyway so you know who knows where this
is going to go
no place good i don't think
tom thanks very much for joining us
today from tennessee